[Music]
revenge chanting death to america death
to israel
iranian mps voting to expand iran's
nuclear programme
and halt you in inspections prompting
this reaction in his first interview
since the crisis began from the man in
charge of those inspections
if implemented these measures would be
even a further deviation
from the commitments that iran entered
into when he joined the agreement and i
cannot imagine
who would win from such a situation
if there was any limitation
if the iaea inspectors
as a result of this or any other
situation
were curtailed in their work
the crisis over the killing of nuclear
scientist mossen faquazade
is escalating jeopardizing efforts to
restrain iran's atomic ambitions
iran had a stockpile of 7 000 kilograms
of enriched uranium before the iranian
nuclear deal
in 2015. the agreement restricted it to
only 202 kilograms
but in may 2018 america pulled out of
the deal
and iran started enriching again at a
higher level it now has almost two and a
half thousand kilograms
enough say experts to start building the
bomb within a year
iran's nuclear programme is in sites
dotted across the country the iaea
inspects most of them
but is still being denied access to
takezabad in tehran despite the
discovery of suspicious radioactive
material there
the fear now is of more surprises like
the killing of fakhrazade
destabilizing the situation even further
but i hope
uh things like this uh do not do not
happen
neither in the past or or in the future
that this is obvious i'm the head of an
international organization dealing with
peace
and security and non-proliferation so
i i hope there is no further escalation
i hope that there is
uh that we can continue working in the
way
we must british diplomats here at the
foreign office and their french and
german counterparts
have issued a joint statement warning
that iran's latest moves could
jeopardize any chances
of reviving the nuclear deal they hope
iran
is bluffing posturing ahead of any
potential resumption
in negotiations at the moment events
seem to be moving
in the other direction analysts say
there's a danger the aftermath of
faculty's killing could escalate still
further
there's a real possibility that donald
trump or israel
would respond militarily if iran does
increase the enrichment to 20
or stop inspections if iran stops
inspections or raises enrichment and
there's a military strike against iran's
nuclear facilities
iran's not going to sit back and take it
this would lead to another war
in the middle east what one president
started
the next one wants to try and put out
joe biden may want to reduce tensions
and revive the iran deal
but there's a danger this crisis
escalates beyond control
even before he moves into the white
house dominic waghorn sky news